en el último vídeo de escribir cómo
interpretar una gráfica en tres
dimensiones y aquí tenemos otra gráfica
tridimensional pero esta tiene muchas
lomas verdad y muchos valles y esta
resulta ser la gráfica de fx
fx igual al coseno de x x el seno del
seno de ella y también podríamos decir
que esta gráfica o más bien 6 y digamos
la gráfica representa el valor z verdad
porque 7 es igual al valor que toma la
función en cada uno de estos puntos
porque pensamos que la salida de la
función es la coordenada 7 en cada punto
y lo que quiero hacer aquí es describir
cómo podemos interpretar la relación
entre la gráfica y las funciones que
conocemos al tomar cortes de esta
gráfica así que por ejemplo digamos que
tomamos un corte con el siguiente plano
que voy a pintar aquí digamos que
hacemos este corte de verdad y lo que
tenemos en este plano en realidad
representa el valor x igual
y puedes ver esto porque este es el eje
x verdad aquí tenemos el eje xy cuando
estamos en cero para el valor x bueno
pasamos por el origen y tenemos valores
de jay-z que pueden ir libremente así
que terminamos con este plano y digamos
que queremos considerar digamos donde
corta a la gráfica así que vamos a
limitarnos a nuestra gráfica justo a los
puntos donde corta verdad y ahora vamos
a dibujar esta línea roja que en
realidad parece una onda sinusoidal y de
hecho es exactamente la función seno
verdad sabemos que pasa por el origen y
luego empieza a subir y luego todo esto
cobra sentido verdad si empezamos a
encajar todo lo que sabemos de la
función seno esto ocurre debido a que si
ponemos x igual a cero en nuestra
función entonces y bueno si dejamos
libre a la variable y lo que significa
es que vamos a ver vamos a ver
tendremos coseno de cero por el seno de
iu por el seno de iu por el seno de iu
y ahora nos preguntamos cuánto vale el
coseno de 0 bueno coseno de 0 es
exactamente 1 verdad entonces toda esta
función simplemente se vería como el
seno de iu que es justamente lo que
obtenemos cuando dejamos correr
libremente al valor y y esto es lo que
estará representado por nuestra
coordenada zeta que sigue siendo nuestro
valor de salida verdad y esto nos da una
gráfica que es una gráfica en dos
dimensiones normal verdad como la
conocemos y vamos ahora a hacer otro
punto distinto qué pasaría si en lugar
de poner x igual a cero imaginamos que
ponemos ye igual a cero y antes de
graficar todo esto y mostrar qué es lo
que va a ocurrir vamos a tratar de
descubrirlo solamente de la fórmula que
tenemos ok entonces qué pasaría si
nosotros ponemos ya igual a cero en
nuestra fórmula así que vamos a hacerlo
del otro lado tenemos
efe d
pero verdad vamos a dejar que x sea
libre entonces vamos a tener coseno de x
verdad eso era algo que podríamos
esperar y luego multiplicamos por el
seno de 0 pero si nos preguntamos cuánto
vale el seno de 0 pues sabemos que esto
vale 0 verdad así que el 0 se cancela y
0 por coseno de x todo esto en realidad
nos da 0 verdad así que lo que podríamos
esperar es que esto se vea como una
función constante y de hecho esa
constante tiene que ser cero así que
vamos a ver si es lo que obtenemos vamos
a hacer el corte con nuestro plano ya
igual a cero y vemos qué es lo que
ocurre en este en este caso verdad vemos
que si dejamos a x y z correr libremente
entonces justamente aquí estamos viendo
la línea recta verdad es la línea que va
a lo largo del eje x pero ahora digamos
que hiciéramos este mismo ejercicio pero
con otro valor del otro que no sea igual
a cero así que vamos a borrar todo esto
vamos a borrar todo esto y digamos que
cortamos toda la gráfica en
otro valor así que en este caso vamos a
elegir el caso de igualdad y medios
entonces esto se ve como una onda aquí
verdad y parece una onda de una onda de
coseno verdad es una función cosa en hoy
y quizás puedas ver de dónde viene todo
esto entonces si dejamos a x correr
libremente y empezamos a graficar todo
esto entonces en realidad vamos a
obtener coseno de x verdad si mantenemos
allí constante en mi medio es verdad
entonces seno de pi medios en realidad
esto lo podemos ver así verdad tendremos
coseno de x por el seno de pi medios
como seno de pi medios es en realidad
uno verdad entonces simplemente
sustituimos todo esto con un 1 y esto
significa que toda la función se verá
como coseno de x verdad entonces
nuevamente nuestra función de varias
variables cuando hemos congelado nuestro
valor de ley y dejamos a x correr
libremente termina viéndose como una
función coseno y yo creo que esta es una
muy buena forma de entender las gráficas
en tres dimensiones una vez que lo ves
digamos si nos vamos a la gráfica
original
aquí tenemos la gráfica original vamos a
quitar todo lo que nos estorbaba
entonces esto se ve como muy ondeado y
tiene muchas lomas verdad y es quizás un
poquito difícil de entender al inicio
pero en términos digamos de mantener una
variable constante entonces todo se
reduce a entenderlo en con gráficas
normales de dos dimensiones y en
realidad podemos pensar que es lo que le
ocurre a la amplitud de nuestra onda al
salir y yendo y viniendo con distintos
planos verdad está esta idea se volverá
muy importante por cierto cuando
introduzcamos la noción de derivada
parcial